[Music]
awesome then let's jump in here well
welcome to the data science hangout
everybody nice to see you all back here
and if this is your first time joining
us a special welcome to you as well it's
so nice to meet you I'm Rachel I lead
customer marketing at
posit um I i' like to start asking this
but is this anybody's First Data data
science hangout say hi in the chat
because we'd love to welcome you in and
say hello to anybody joining for the
first time
too but this is our open space to chat
about data Science Leadership questions
you're facing and getting to hear about
what's going on in the world of data
across different Industries so we're
here every Thursday at the same time
same place if you're watching this
recording on YouTube later the link to
add it to your calendar will be in the
details below as well um I said every
Thursday but just a heads up we will be
off next week for the Thanksgiving
holiday um but at the Hangouts we're all
dedicated to making this a welcoming
environment for everyone love hearing
from everybody no matter your years of
experience your titles the languages you
work in or
industry it is totally okay to just
listen in here uh maybe you're walking
your dog you're on your lunch break or
just want to listen in for the first one
but there's also ways you can jump in
and ask questions or provide your own
perspective so you can jump in by
raising your hand on zoom and I'll keep
my eye out you can put questions in the
zoom chat and feel free to put a little
star next to it if you want me to read
it or I can call on you to introduce
yourself and add some content context
and then we also have a slid link which
Curtis will share in a second here where
you can ask questions anonymously
too just before we get started I wanted
to share if you are hiring feel free to
share any roles in the chat here that's
definitely not spammy to us um the
Biogen team actually shared one with me
earlier today so I just wanted to share
it in the the chat
there one more shout out if anybody is
in
Boston um Kevin and I are hosting tidy
Tuesday Meetup tonight yes on a Thursday
um but that's at Microsoft in Cambridge
so I'm just GNA put that in there as
well but with that I am so excited to
introduce my co-host for today Stephanie
lucier manager of biostatistics at madna
and Stephanie I'd love to have you
introduce yourself and share a little
bit about your role and also something
you like to do outside of work sure um
so thank you for the brief introduction
um as you said I'm currently a manager
of biostatistics at madna and I sit in
our specialty data analytics team um so
a little bit about my background I
graduated with a master's in biostats in
2017 and then proceeded to work at a cro
a contract research Organization for 5
years um and during that time I had what
some might call a little bit more of a
traditional statistician role um within
the clinical trial
realm um and was doing open source
projects kind of more on the side like a
20% time kind of deal um and so in
2022 I kind of got to the point where I
really wanted that to be a bigger part
of my role and so that's where I found
my current position at madna um and so
I'm in the specialty data analytics team
and our mission kind of in in simple
terms is to just use clinical data with
modern open-source
Technologies um to really enable
internal decision
making so that's where I am now and have
happy to talk more about it and um
outside of work um I kind of collect
like Pokemon cards and as a result of
that I'm definitely like Jack of all
trades master of none which I'm okay
with and so some of those hobbies
include yoga that's kind of a big one
for me um I've been learning to play
tennis um I make a lot of sourdough I'm
learning to throw pots on the wheel and
I do like to travel and when I travel I
do like to scuba dive so
I'm happy to talk about hobbies for an
entire hour I love them I hope everyone
has awesome
hobbies yeah wait can you tell me a bit
more about what throwing pots on the
wheel means uh so like using clay to
make
pottery um and so a lot of that at my
skill level means making cups and bowls
that aren't very symmetrical but are
supposed to be um it's very relaxing for
me like I can't draw at all or paint or
anything of that type and so this is
kind of an art form that I can do a
little
bit I love it that's awesome oh I wanted
to throw in one little tidbit if you
don't mind um so with all due respect to
past data leaders um I thought a little
bit about what my goal is being on the
data science hangout today and um for
those that don't know
the leaders are great but the chat is
where it's at and so my goal is just for
people to have fun in the chat so go
crazy it has resources it has debates um
it has fun
topics and if you've never participated
in the chat before I'd encourage you to
do so if you want to I love it thank you
so for that call out to the chat yes the
chat is is always a
party I see the excitement starting
already in
there well Stephanie while we are
waiting for some questions to come in
from everybody here um I know something
that we talked a bit about is becoming a
manager for the first time and I'm
curious if there's something that you've
learned or you had to learn throughout
this process of becoming a manager that
you'd be able to share with us sure um
so a lot of pieces of of this um in my
previous role like I said more as like a
traditional
statistician um you work within clinical
teams and so um you end up doing some
management of like statistical outputs
so that is kind of like managing
statisticians and programmers on a
project level and I think that was
really good preparation for being an
actual true manager
um and so now I'm on a team we have
seven full-time employees and seven um
contractors and um starting to pick up
part of like the true management pieces
of that um but let's see as far as what
I've learned there's a lot of paperwork
parts of it and so hopefully anyone
becoming a manager has some sort of
mentor walking them through that part of
it um for example requesting a laptop is
a pretty difficult goal to achieve
apparently um shout out to our awesome
digital team who helps with that uh so
learning like those little technical
pieces of it is like a whole new world
to just take on slowly and and ask
questions I think that's the most
important
thing um and then as far as actual
management I think just forming a
relationship with people um working
closely together asking them to ask
questions um just really like creating a
comfortable space has been really
important for me thank you I see Bill
jumped in right away with a question and
I know you said you want me to to ask it
um but the question was when you
graduate or what is the language that
you use in your academic program did you
need to learn SAS when you joined the
cro is the question and maybe acronyms
will expand on them a bit too yeah I'm
doing my very best with not over using
acronym so please catch me if I do um
yeah so in the clinical trial World the
Main statistical language that is used
right now is SAS um I don't know what
SAS stands for it's fine um uh but it's
a statistical programming language so
during my grad school I was lucky enough
to learn both um SAS andr and even some
python um and I think that really guided
where I ended up today so SAS was taught
in certain classes that I had and in
other classes the professors favored R
and I think um the reason I really ended
up on the r path was that my main thesis
project was done INR um and so that
really gave me a strong foundation so
that when I started my first role it was
definitely expected to use um SAS in
that more traditional setting but I was
able to connect with the people in my
first
organization um who did use R and that
really kicked off um thinking more about
developing with r um and what are in the
clinical trial space looks like thank
you yeah um something that you and I had
chatted a little bit about before is
that you've kind of realized like people
don't want to look at these standard um
like tables listings and figures which I
just learned that's what tlfs means when
I see that like listed or named in uh in
Pharma um but I I'm
curious like in building tools for
internal decision making
um what has been really helpful for you
in in
communicating yeah so the fun thing too
about the tlf abbreviation is that it
goes by many
abbreviations so watch out for that it
can be tlf tfl tlg tgl and it all means
the same thing right on top of it in the
chat
too um and and why is it like that I
think that's just to confuse people um
and I think that's a common theme with
abbreviation and clinical trials so to
actually answer the question um yeah a
big part of my role is creating
visualizations for internal decision
making and so we think a lot about what
is the best way to do that um I think
one of the most important questions is
what is the question that someone is
trying to answer and who is the end user
um and so for example a lot of times the
end user for us is say the executive
committee um and so people on the
executive committee at madna at least um
are highly skilled professionals um you
know they're not looking for a green
button or a red button they want to know
what were the results and they want to
see it in a you know a visually
pleasing straightforward display but
they also still want to know some key
statistical elements
and so that's actually part of the
reason why a lot of the people on our
team have a statistics background is
because we are still you know displaying
confidence intervals and risk ratios in
our
displays um and so that's an example
where we know the audience and we know
the questions they're going to ask um
another example would be we create say
visualizations that are going to be used
by the clinical iCal team that want to
look at data in an ongoing way and so
you might think about how well those
people know this data and they want to
know every nitty-gritty about it and so
that's where something like interactive
applications really comes into play so
that as they form their own questions
they can answer those questions that's
great can you can you share maybe an
example for us or example use case where
people wor able to answer some of their
own questions with an interactive app uh
sure so I'm working one of the big
projects that I work on both internally
and externally right now is um patient
profiles and so the whole goal with
patient profiles is that you can look at
one particular participant in a study
and the primary uses there is really for
safety um so you could look at say their
Labs uh basic demographics information
there what we call Adverse Events so any
safety signals that happened through
this study um and so we had a
participant that had an
unexpected um response in a
biomarker um and so they were able to
use the patient profile to look at when
that particular biomarker uptick
occurred what else was going on for that
particular participant
thank you I think Bill's question maybe
expands a bit on this let's
see um was that that visualization was
that a shiny application I think Bill's
question was have you developed shiny
based apps for your internal users um
and have you ended up using the same
interactive or static
visualizations in drill Downs when
interacting with the
FDA okay that's like three questions we
can break we caning break it up a bit
yeah oh that's okay um
so so much to say here so the particular
example I provided um was Act is
actually all being powered by non shiny
interactivity and there's been a couple
of great talks about this topic lately
um deep sha gave a hilarious talk at
posit comp um about this and my mentor
Augustine catron also had a recorded
talk at R farmer where he kind of
touched on this as well um and so kind
of with a judicious use of cross talk
plotly um interactive tables you can
make an interactive HTML
document um that has a limited but
pretty good
capabilities um and so that is the
current platform for that particular
patient profile
um so yeah if you're not familiar with
that setup I do think it's powerful um
in my previous company we didn't really
have a good hosting platform and so we
were able to really utilize that setup
um to create interactive
reports like at a high level the
limitation is that the interactivity
happens on one level sort of and there's
no like recalculation happening of the
data you're essentially filtering the
data um but you can you can really do a
lot with that
setup um so then moving to like shiny
land it's definitely something that our
team uses um we have a variety of
different
visualizations um and so that that
decision is kind of part of like what we
talked about earlier when you get say a
data visualization request deciding what
is the right technology and so if more
and more exploration is the goal then
shiny I think is the way to go um and we
definitely utilize
that and then I think the third question
is about sending that to the
FDA and that's not something that we're
doing right now um but I think probably
a lot of folks are following um the our
submissions group and they've done a
pilot to look at what a shiny app to the
FDA could look like and they're going to
be doing more um utilizing the web R
framework um which is a hot hot exciting
topic right now um that could apply
really well for this concept of shiny to
FDA so many
answers great
job um and I guess probably fun to just
throw it out here as well that some of
the the team from the FDA is actually
going to be joining us at the hangout um
in on February 1 so putting it out there
so people know as well but I see a lot
of love for cross talk in the chat it
feels like we should have some sort of
event on that at some point St event
very awesome awesome SE uh CA I see you
asked a question in the chat do you want
to jump in here yeah hi thanks um so I'm
curious um from a more management
perspective how did you kind of navigate
this um transition from a more uh
day-to-day interactions with more bio
statisticians who knew the same language
and we're talking the same way versus to
working at madna where um you kind of
have to interface with a whole different
group of people say biologists data
scientists um very diverse kind of group
of people uh assuming that it it was
less diverse in the sense of bi having
more bi statisticians in your previous
role um and kind of what challenges did
you have and kind of how did you deal
with that okay yeah I love that question
um I think it's an awesome part about
the clinical trial world is that you do
get to interface with people in so many
different roles um and I would say that
at my previous position I did interface
with a lot of different types of people
already and so maybe that was good
preparation um working with clinicians
on the trial I even used to have phone
calls with like people at the sites um
that was always fun to like feel more a
part of the trial um so I think I
definitely already have had cross
functional area training um so then
moving to madna I think part of the
difference is the group that we're in
now is very much like a support team um
so we have like presence on every study
and and our role is a little bit like
we're here to help you how do we help
does this help you um and so gaining a
pretty good understanding of what would
help people um is really important so
that we can deliver tools that are
useful did that answer your question a
little bit thank you so
much thank you Russ I still had a
question in the chat you want to jump in
here next sure thanks um I similar to
you uh wind up sending reports up and
stuff and sometimes the feedback that
I'll get is good and sometimes like eh
what's one thing that the leadership
does that's good that's helpful to you
that gets them the report that they
actually
want yeah I love that um so like what is
good feedback and what is less helpful
feedback
um I'm
thinking good
feedback um is for them to tell us
how and why a report was or wasn't
useful um so that we can then apply it
to Future
reports um and so the why I think is
important um and maybe you have to ask
the why um because if they just
say this didn't
help um that's not useful so getting
like a better understanding of what they
were looking for maybe um an
understanding of you know a report
answers the question that they asked
hopefully but if that question changed
over time and that's why the report is
no longer helpful um a little bit of
insight into like how that question
might have changed or why that question
might have changed helps us kind of
predict in the
future um how questions might change or
how we can provide supplemental
materials that might answer those
changing
questions so yeah I think I think like
the Takeaway on that is it's okay to
turn it into a conversation and probe a
little bit more so that you can um can
move forward and improve for the
future okay thank you yeah did you have
any thoughts you wanted to add
Russ um yeah I'll just make it really
quick uh I have a lot of Prior careers
one of which I'm actually a professional
counselor um with a masters and the
whole thing so to me listening is really
really really critical um I think that's
almost more important than the analysis
so just make sure that I really truly
understand what the question is and if I
can give a professional counselor tip
for just a second also find out what it
is
not because when you find out what it is
you might go four miles down that path
and find oh it's actually something
slightly different I was working on that
no we don't want that is it this and not
that and once you do that a lot of
things clear up and then it's easy to
move
forward awesome yeah I previously did a
lot of work on manuscript writing um and
so in traditional clinical trials you
have your end points um that are
pre-written and you answer those
endpoints that are pre-specified um and
sometimes in a more exploratory
biomarker manuscript setting
um there can be a lot of back and forth
like you're talking about with questions
changing over time and so keeping the
conversation flowing was always um
important to really narrow the scope and
try to find the answers that they were
looking for I see a lot of great
thoughts on this topic too in the chat I
don't know if Katherine you wanted to
share your thoughts here too yeah um I
was just I'll kind of repeat what I said
in the chat is one of the things that
that I learn to ask for is like what
questions are my leadership being asked
that led them to ask me to do something
because how they're interpreting their
own like the questions that they're
being asked and then there's like three
levels of information distillation
before they ask you for a piece of math
or a piece of reporting or a
visualization um and so then you make
the thing that you think they were
asking for but it doesn't really meet
the ask that their leadership ask them
for and so there's a little bit of a
cycle there and so getting plugged into
meetings where you can like listen to
how like your leadership talks about
these kinds of things or being forwarded
emails or things like that can really
help you get a broader picture of like
where your organization fits within like
the broader thing so oh okay this is how
the reports that I deliver are used by
these other teams to get more of a sense
of like okay what information
is actually important to the ultimate
like decision
making yeah one of the comments that you
touched on Catherine um is something
that we kind of prioritize in our team
and that's asking to get invited to the
meetings um to kind of parse down the
amount of distillation that occurs um
and so no one wants a calendar full of
meetings when there's lots of you know
deep work to do but when important um
asking to get invited so you can hear
the whole conversation instead of the
summary Lisa I see you had some nice uh
feedback on this as well do you w to do
you want to share
that um sorry I feel like I wrote a lot
today are you talking about just like
the comparison to um feedback from
students or yeah yeah into teaching yeah
yeah no I was just more I I don't I have
much to add besides that it just sort of
triggered in my mind that it reminded me
of teaching and when I'd get these
responses um especially when I first
started teaching that they would be like
you're awful or you're really nice and I
was like oh I feel really lovely that
you think I'm nice or I feel terrible
that you think I'm awful but neither of
those really help me um so I always ask
them to be like as specific as possible
um but but I've never thought of asking
someone at work for that specific uh
feedback so that
was a nice connection is all I was
saying thank you for sharing yeah I'm
trying trying to call out some of the
the chat comments as well because I know
when people watch the recording they
don't get the advantage of getting to
see all these amazing comments
too um I know let's see Adrian you asked
a question in the chat a bit earlier do
you want to jump in yeah let me see if I
can recall it and and and restate it
pretty clearly
um I'm interested in U Stephanie at
madna and with sort of the the profile
of work you're doing how recyclable is
um sort of those analyses or those
reports um and if you want a bit of
context I spend a lot of time trying to
not do anything multiple times um so I'm
curious if um the the biostats area or
at least you know with your team if
there is a lot of opportunity to library
your um sort of starting points or what
have
you yes great question um this short
very short answer is yes there's a lot
of
recyclability and um I think a lot of
similar teams as well as mine are
working on you know creating internal
packages that help
with that recyclability um but something
like has kind of been on my mind lately
is making sure that when you're creating
functions modules whatever um you're
still allowing for customization because
at least in my experience um what people
in clinical teams they they want to add
stuff they want to say can we look at
this too can you add this facet um um
you know even little details um and so
as we go on you know making progress um
in creating like an internal package
system um that's something that we're
trying to keep in mind is finding that
sweet spot between out of the box boom
here you go I made you this plot and
allowing for um
customization thumbs up awesome
I want to jump to a few of the anonymous
questions too and one
was do you have any advice for a recent
graduate trying to get her foot in the
door it's a bit hard to do currently
okay um we're all with you it's not easy
um my job search to switch jobs took
what felt like a long time I I don't
want to like put a number on it um like
I was always told saans can get a new
job so quickly and I was really picky in
my situation and so it wasn't quick and
I did have like fear surrounding that
that I look back on now and it all make
sense you know um so but for thinking
about someone with less
experience um I saw the chat going this
direction last week which is a topic
that I think is really cool to talk
about is the presence of like an online
GitHub uh
repository because I think there's
Arguments for and against this um but I
think in a position of being a recent
grad that's something that I would think
about doing is do some little tiny
projects and put them on GitHub just to
demonstrate your programming
skills um and then in the clinical trial
space if if you're having difficulty I
would suggest looking at contract
research organizations I learned so much
in that role um and I think they have a
lot of
positions hopefully for more entry level
um it like I hope I'm not making too big
of generalizations I think sometimes the
Fara side of thing does look for more
experience and there are more entry
levels associate type rules um in the
cro world so that's something to like
look into and read more about um and
then another thing I would think about
is I don't know um exactly your
background but um the CR or the clinical
trials world has a lot of clinical
trials
knowledge um and so trying to find some
resources online to become familiar with
what a clinical trial looks like like um
we have data standards called cisk um to
do a little bit of research about that
um I think that would make you really
stand out as a
candidate thank
you um Matt m i see you had a question a
bit earlier do you want do you want to
jump in and read that
one sure um so I was curious you talked
about some of the dashboards you've
built um and I'm just curious what's the
limiting principle for how much
interactivity to give people because
I've kind of found that there are two
sides to that Continuum one you can just
keep building the app and building the
app and adding more
functionality um but you want to deliver
it um and then the more content you add
the more the more functionality you add
to it the more possibility someone
someone else pointed out that there's a
possibility that people are going to you
know derive insights that aren't
necessarily true or meaningful but then
on the flip side you know that the one
thing you don't Implement is the thing
you're going to get asked for so so
where where do you draw the line on uh
what to do and what to lead
out that's that's a big question it's
difficult to like nail down um I think
like in my particular realm of things
you can I definitely think about it
along the lines of where a study is
progressing so um in the early early
phases of a clinical trial things or
even pre-clinical things can be much
more
exploratory um and so when exploratory
is the goal hypothesis generating is the
goal um you know go
crazy uh and put a
disclaimer that you know there are
things discoverable here that need to be
proven outside of this application
um and then when you work your way down
to you know questions that are more
formulated um a researcher has really
provided the question they're trying to
answer I wouldn't I would that's where I
would think about limiting it um and
trying to really just answer the
question that's being asked and limit
the back and forth um because you know
there's a whole Theory behind this but
when you're in phase three of a clinical
trial the question should be laid out
and the question should be answerable um
and that upholds the entire Integrity of
the trial so that's kind of how I think
about
it no that's great thank you I also
really appreciate the
disclaimer principle yeah use
disclaimers I see um Abigail and Jesse
you had some thoughts on this topic too
do you want to jump in
here I'm not sure if you're in places
where you can jump in or not but I'll
give a second here oh was this about
interactivity yeah oh yeah no I was just
saying like I don't know I real
dashboards I don't know I've dashboards
are tough because people do like you
give people self- analytics and then
they come to conclusions which are wrong
sometimes so figuring how to sort of
manage that I think can I don't know I
found that to be difficult um so like I
just want to give somebody like I wrote
you a paper I made do a PowerPoint thing
um as as useful as as the interactivity
definitely can
be
definitely um Kevin I see you had a
question in the chat want to jump in
here sure yeah uh what was my
question uh sorry I know when there's
like a lot of chat it gets hard to
remember what our questions were yeah it
was about oh that's right now I remember
it was it was about um deep work and as
a manager and and the question was
basically like you know are you are you
able to manage to to carve out time to
do deep work still or do you have to
delegate most of that you know or how do
you how do you kind of handle
that yeah um so generally I would say
that my manager workload like workload
as a manager is not 40 hours a week in
any way right now um and so I definitely
find time time to carve out for deep
work and I also am not overloaded on
meetings which I know what that looks
like from previous experience as well um
and so it definitely is doable I think
part of that is because our group is so
young um everyone is heads down creating
stuff doing work um focusing and so um
that kind of contributes get to like an
overall environment where we're all uh
getting in hours for Deep work yeah but
do you end up having to to hit um you
know attend lots of meetings that they
don't have to go to you know to
interface with your your end you know
with the people that you guys are
serving you know or other management and
things like that or yeah right now I
really feel like that is being handled
well like the meetings that I'm
attending are um um relevant and
helpful um and I could see of course how
that could
change um but yeah I think it's
something to always keep in the front of
your mind is time
resourcing um I I'm like a fan of time
blocking in my calendar and so always
asking the question do I need to be at
this meeting what am I getting out of
this meeting and you you don't always
hit the nail on ahead you go to a
meeting that uh you shouldn't have been
at or you miss a meeting that you should
have been at um but just always like
keeping it in the Forefront of your mind
um I think is an important
skill right thanks so much yeah it's
been something I've been thinking a lot
about recently as well like initially
when you get invited to like a meeting
with a new team it like feels good like
oh I'm they want my point view in this
conversation and then when I realize
okay that meeting is every week or every
other
week at at what point can you then say
okay no I don't think I need to be at
this meeting every week and like how do
you communicate that to people that know
you're you're just not going to attend
yeah um I think as as soon as you're
saying to yourself is this useful
it might not be useful um and so just
making it a conversation I think but
it's it's it's not easy um but yeah I
think it's something to for any career
person to like always be thinking
about I see a few ideas here in the chat
Donald do you want to jump in uh sure
just like as far as uh carving out deep
work time I think I had some questions
too so I'll try and answer those um I
usually block out two to three hour
chunks multiple times a week um you know
I think it's also recommended Inc for
book to do that too and I've been doing
it ever since and it's been extremely
helpful I think Jared you asked if
people ever complain that I never
available sometimes but you know I also
notify my director who I report to like
oh you know I'm doing this this is
really important because I'm knowledge
worker I need this time to do that and
he's completely on board with it um so
usually we kind of lose and if we need
to a discussion of priorities to see um
if anything else need to happen so I I
um see that Frank is on the call and I
don't mean to call on you but something
that's always stuck with me that you
said Frank is like you color code some
of the meetings that you have on your
calendar and like the ones that give you
energy are a certain color and the ones
that and maybe I'm putting words in your
mouth that are more draining or a
different color and I thought that was a
really interesting approach
too I hope Frank your calendar doesn't
face all of your co-workers in that
case but you know honestly even if it
does um that's fine with me uh and me
like all right so so most of this came
when I was at Target uh and Target huge
company right like most of us work in
huge companies and um yeah I mean in
those cases I I was always pretty hon
honest about that stuff I was like hey
yeah I'm going to show up right like
this is a little bit draining for me but
right I know it's important for me to
hear this I know it's important for me
to be here when you do the color color
coding it makes it very easy to see like
hey red red red red red and then right
like the last Red meeting is something
that's really important and like you
have to be paying attention and on top
of it and I mean all of us love to find
patterns in data right even if your your
sample size is like really small um and
then being able to just like reflect on
that and notice that oh man I'm not
there's no way I'm going to be able to
give my focus and attention and 100% at
like this really important meeting to
like the one-on-one with a team member
or right like the big meeting with the
VP if you can know how you will be and
then sharing that with other people
around you like people are surprisingly
or maybe not surprising like willing to
adjust so I I I've always been a fan of
that visibility um if it rubs people the
wrong way way it's going to be even
worse for the whole organization if like
you show up to this really important
meeting and you're drained so it's been
my
philosophy okay I'm thinking of like a
scatter plot where we're plotting like
importance versus passion maybe and so
really important no passion kind of
still got to go less important tons of
passion when there's time for it like we
have quadrants is that along the lines
of your thought process yeah but a the
way um you describe that and the way I'm
visualizing it like none of this stuff
lives in a silo right like it's all
connected and especially like the series
of meetings leading up to something
important before like you can go on a
walk if you're in Minneapolis and in the
Skyway and like re re-energize yourself
um so I'm not exactly sure maybe we can
like put together a three-dimensional
scatter plot so we can see these right
like time would be your your other axis
time of day is important and that's your
third dimension okay very
cool we should uh we should write that
one out
yeah Mike I see you had a question
earlier on
um as a consultant when somebody asks
can you help me do X do you want to jump
in and continue that question I think
that was very much related to what you
were talking about previously on the
okay why is someone asking for a report
um but it's it it would be interesting
to hear what Stephanie thinks that you
know sometimes I get these messages that
go Mike can you get this package for me
or could you show me how to do that
thing without any context and you know
as a consultant you might think well
I'll just jump in and I'll help I'll
I'll just do it you know help them get
that thing but then if you one pick it
you realize that actually you know
there's a whole world of you know either
there there's a better solution or you
know there's a simpler thing that they
could do or you know it's related to you
know back to the why
question so you know
it's you can be the helpful consultant
or you can actually do something that
makes that you know eliminates Tech debt
or you know makes makes it's easier to
maintain or
something yeah I think I'm I'm coming to
mind with examples just within my own
team um of getting like a ping
saying how do I Stephanie how do I make
this access log 10 and it's it's
probably a good idea to first ask why
why are you making that access log 10
these kinds of things um to try to make
sure you're solving the right an
question yeah I like that Brenan I see
you just asked a question want to jump
in here
next uh yes ma'am uh the question I
wanted to ask you just um what's the
most fulfilling project you have worked
on so far in your career oh I I really
like that question it um like gives me a
good moment to reflect back like you
know we talk about data science and
clinical trials but clinical trials are
like a big deal um they affect people's
lives and that definitely is a huge
motivator for me in my
day-to-day um and it's always important
to like think back like this data is a
person giving up their time giving up
theirselves to help improve science and
like I'm giving myself chills like it's
just such an awesome thing to be a part
of um and
so uh there's so much cool stuff
happening at madna um that could make
very big advancements in the Science
World um but me
personally um my answer definitely has
to be that in my previous role I worked
on a really big food allergy trial um
and it would essentially be the first
actual
treatment uh like a antibody approved to
treat food allergy um and it was a
Behemoth of a study um no one wanted to
work on it it was very
complicated but it was so rewarding to
think that you're helping children who
can't have lunch in the
cafeteria um change their lives and so
um I was really proud of the work I did
on that study it was an awesome team and
they've completed it without me so um
yeah it it was a really good experience
oh and I'll add to that um I had a
colleague once I was off this study I
had a former colleague whose child
joined the study so that's super cool to
actually like feel so connected to the
study um and so again hearing from his
point of view oh my gosh we the doctors
all the time this is so much work and
like on our side that's like this
schedule of events is insane I don't
know how to program the visits data set
um like those two things go hand in hand
and our side is easier like I think
always keep that in
mind yeah thanks for asking
that thank you I love that question
Brennan uh Natalia I see you had a
question earlier in the hangout you want
to jump in
here yeah sure we are on such a great
note I don't know like if switching back
to
programming um yeah but thank you so uh
you mentioned that Mna it's kind of open
to open source and um those tools so I'm
very curious if in your day-to-day work
you're using any like Pharma ver
packages or any other farma related open
source packages and like overall how
you're approaching the open- source
projects at madna are you going to
release some open source your like as
well within your company so stuff like
this yeah great we love like I I mean I
love open source I think that's why
we're here in this hangout because we
all love open source um so yeah your
question had a lot of different parts
again so um as far as our team using
Pharma verse so a little background for
non-pharma people Pharma verse is a
collection of packages um contributed to
by all different Pharma companies um as
well as
Euros um and the aim of the phe packages
is largely to do a submission so
actually putting a drug in front of the
FDA for approval um and that is not
where my group is using open source
software at this time uh we're very much
keeping our eyes and ears open to it and
if that's something you're interested in
and you haven't yet watched Nova Nordic
you YouTube video someone can put it in
the chat um that's like very
groundbreaking very exciting it was
presented beautifully um and we're very
happy at madna to see these companies
laying the path for us um very
appreciative of those companies as well
as all the initiatives that surround
that um so yeah that's not totally our
focus and so I don't see us using
pharmers packages at ton um that being
said we have a safety stats group that
are also open-source folks and they have
developed um similar table
packages um for what looks more like an
FDA reporting output um and again those
are currently being used internally but
as a part of that work um and this is to
answer another part of your question
there is a member of that team or
several members of that team that do
participate in phae open source um like
the Falcon package um and
so in general I find that leadership is
very open to um open source
collaboration thank you let's
see if I know as we get to the end of
the time here if you have a question
that we maybe missed in the chat among
all the amazing conv ation in there
please raise your hand here so we can
get to it as well um but Jared I see you
had a question a little bit earlier if
you want to jump in
next sure can you guys hear me okay um I
guess like in the cro space you bring up
you know a few good points but I think
for me it's more like transitioning and
towing the line between a statistician
or programming role I've seen a lot
more individual struggle going from a
program to a statistician then from a
statistician to a programmer and so the
thing that I keep finding myself
wondering is like do you find yourself
missing some programming aspects where
you're kind of just inundated with
writing up saps and protocols versus
actually getting to do some of the work
and then you know from that same kind of
same coin going back and thinking you
know the role that you're in as a
statistician if it's more of a standard
role or one of discovery
and trying to stay in that Niche or
being more kind of fluid in in the roles
that you take on like you said you're
very picky about that for that I didn't
know if that had partially had to do
with the reason
so yeah um really great question it's
interesting to see like I've seen
colleagues over time switching between
programming and statistics and that's
always kind of telling about a person
passion um and how that might change
over time I think it's really cool I
actually think right now in my current
role I have a very good mix of
Statistics programming management um
kind of all Blended together um which
for me works well I like doing all of
those things um and like to your a
couple of things so I think we're going
to see maybe the definition between
statisticians and programmers change
over time um like where that line is
drawn um and that future roles might
start looking a little bit different um
I I think there's already several
companies that are kind of calling
everyone a data scientist now and
blurring those lines um and so I think
you know within that idea of Blurred
Lines it's important to know what you
like and advocate for yourself to do
what you like um and then another piece
of that that's something I I I really
like to speak about this when I'm
interviewing candidates for our team um
is to have an open conversation about
you know like you said I was seeking out
um this change from a traditional
statistician to what looks a little bit
more like a data scientist you might say
um but like fresh grads to have a
conversation about what that means and
what that means in terms of your career
um I always like to have that
conversation because the industry as it
stands right now um has more of those
traditional roles and maybe it will
change over time but just kind of having
an open conversation about it because it
might be a New Concept for people that
um are new to the industry
thank you yeah so maybe at some point
I'll pull all the answers to these this
question together but I know we've asked
it in a few different Hangouts is there
a piece of career advice that you've
been given or that you've given others
that stands out to
you sure um so when I joined um the SI
we've talked so much about uh back in
2017 I was just very lucky to be be
scooped up by a very passionate Mentor
um who has 100% guided my career and
he's given me so much advice and the
advice is both solicited and
unsolicited um and it ranges a big gamma
you know there's statistics advice
there's programming advice there's
advice about my mortgage there is aice
about how to plan my wedding um and so
it was hard to sift through many many
words of
wisdom um to answer the question but I
think uh let me take this
board I think one thing that I didn't
know at the time was going to be so
important but luckily was very um kind
of like lead by example is how to be a
remote employee that is engaged with a
team um I didn't necessarily think I
would be a remote employee and that
changed and most of us are now um and I
think the single greatest advice is just
pick up the phone like to be a part of
the team so that you're not siloed away
form personal relationships and maybe
not everyone wants to form personal
relationships pick up on that if that's
the case but to call people that you
work with and ask them a question about
work and ask them a question about their
personal life um I think that was one of
one of the better lessons I've learned
so much yeah thank you all for spending
your Thursday with us and thank you
Stephanie for sharing your experience
and knowledge with all of us this has
been great I love the engaging
conversation and definitely one of the
more lively chats as well that's what I
like to
hear bye all have a great rest of the
day thank you so
much